aquí está la reacción de hidroboración
oxidación de alquinos empezamos con
nuestro alquino y usualmente es un
alquino terminal Aquí está tu hidrógeno
Y en el otro lado de nuestro triple
enlace digamos que hay un grupo r unido
a este carbono a nuestro alquino
añadiremos en el primer paso borano bh3
y thf como nuestro solvente y en el
segundo paso añadiremos peróxido de
hidrógeno y al anón hidróxido ooh men y
tendremos adición de agua a través de
nuestro doble enlace Así que es muy
similar a la última reacción la
diferencia aquí es la Regio química esta
Regio
quí
mica es de hecho una adición
anti marcó mico
anti a la regla de
Mark antim markovnikov lo que significa
que el Oh se añadirá al carbono menos
sustituido el cual por supuesto debe de
ser el carbono aquí en la
izquierda terminamos añadiendo
H2O agua a través de nuestro triple
enlace Ahora hay un doble enlace
presente y luego hay un Oh en nuestra
molécula igual que en el último video
formamos un
enol aquí así y el enol por supuesto No
es la forma más estable tendremos algo
de reordenamiento y acabaremos con un
aldeido aquí podemos ver que tenemos un
grupo funcional aldeido de un alquino
terminal al someterlo a esta reacción
ahora algunas veces Si usas borano en
este primer paso de aquí algunas veces
el borano es tan reactivo que de hecho
añadirá dos moléculas a través de tu
triple enlace ya que tu triple enlace
consiste en dos enlaces pi Así que
algunas veces verás que se utiliza una
molécula diferente algunas veces Verás
un dialquil borano entonces pongamos dos
grupos alquilo pondré
r2 B
h y si los haces muy voluminosos el
impedimento estérico previene la segunda
adición del borano porque en el
mecanismo solo quieres una adición de
borano y el borano se añadirá en el
mismo carbono en el que lo hace el
Oh Así que mira el video de
hidroboración oxidación de alquenos para
tener más detalles del primer mecanismo
que
discutimos Entonces el resultado neto de
esta reacción es formar un aldeido de tu
alquino terminal observemos esta
reacción de aquí hagamos nuestro enlace
triple aquí así y lo haremos un alquino
terminal y haremos de este lado un
anillo de
benceno haremos un grupo r bastante
grande
aquí Déjame poner algunos electrones en
mi anillo de
benzeno Dejémoslo así bien si hago
reaccionar este alquino ya sea con un
dialquil borano o solo pondré borano
aquí podrías usar dialquil borano si
quisieras o lo que quiera utilizar tu
profesor y
thf y en el segundo paso peróxido de
hidrógeno y
ooh menos así así que la primer cosa en
la que debes pensar es qué es lo que
pasará estaré añadiendo agua a través de
mi triple enlace y necesito pensar qué
lado se queda con el hidrógeno Y qué
lado obtiene el
Oh nuevamente tengo dos opciones podría
Añadir el Oh al carbono en la derecha
O podría Añadir el Oh al carbono en la
izquierda y aquí la región química es
antim marcov nikov así que añadiré el Oh
al carbono menos sustituido el cual por
supuesto es el carbono en el lado
derecho continuemos dibujando nuestro
doble enlace aquí
primero continuemos dibujando nuestro
anillo de
benzeno continuaré haciendo
así y ese anillo de benzeno está
conectado con un
carbono este carbono de aquí ahora hay
un doble enlace presente así y añadí el
Oh al carbono menos sustituido añadí el
Oh al carbono en la derecha así y añadí
un hidrógeno al carbono en la izquierda
eso está añadiendo mi H2O a través de mi
triple enlace y luego ahí aún había un
hidrógeno en este carbono en la derecha
así ese es mi enol intermedio así y
veamos qué es lo que pasará con ese enol
intermedio se reordenar y en el último
video Vimos una tautomerización
catalizada por ácido en este video una
base está presente tenemos nuestros
aniones hidróxido en solución así que
continuemos dibujando nuevamente nuestro
enol y mostremos al enol reaccionando
con una base continuemos dibujando el
enol aquí otra vez dibujaré al
enol en el lado
derecho Ahí está mi anillo de benceno y
tengo mi doble enlace aquí así y sé que
tengo un
Oh así y dibujo mis pares libres de
electrones y haré reaccionar esto con
aniones hidróxido los aniones hidróxido
están flotando
alrededor el hidróxido está cargado
negativamente Así que el hidróxido
funcionará como una
base Déjame poner mis pares libres de
electrones aquí en mi oxígeno y tomaré
ese
protón y mandaré estos electrones a este
oxígeno continuemos dibujando los
resultados de esa reacción ácido
base es un equilibrio Así que déjame
continuar dibujando mis flechas de
equilibrio así qué es lo que pasará aún
tengo mi anillo de
benzeno
y
tengo mi doble enlace y veamos ahora
tengo mi
oxígeno con tres pares libres de
electrones alrededor así está cargado
negativamente Ahora puedo dibujar una
estructura resonante para esta molécula
continuemos poniendo nuestros corchetes
de
resonancia aquí así
Entonces qué puedo hacer para esparcir
esa carga formal a lo largo de la
molécula bien Podría tomar un par libre
de electrones justo aquí y podría
moverlos a
acá para formar un doble enlace y ahora
di demasiados enlaces a este carbono por
lo que el enlace pi aquí se romperá y
los dos electrones de aquí se moverán a
este carbono
así continuemos dibujando los resultados
del movimiento de esos electrones aún
tengo mi anillo de benzeno así y ahí
está mi esqueleto de
carbonos ahora tengo un carbono
doblemente unido a un
oxígeno solía haber tres pares libres de
electrones alrededor de ese oxígeno de
arriba uno se movió para formar el doble
enlace y ahora solo hay dos pares libres
así y los electrones que solían estar en
este enlace pi se movieron a este
carbono justo aquí este carbono de aquí
aún está unido a otro hidrógeno por lo
que los dos electrones moviéndose hacia
él de hecho formarán un carbanion aquí
por lo que esto es de hecho un carbanión
cargado negativamente
así y el agua ahora está
presente Oh men tomó un protón y se
convirtió en
H2O ahora el
agua está flotando alrededor de esta
manera ahora el agua funcionará como un
ácido donará un protón y este par libre
de electrones tomarán ese protón tomarán
ese protón Y mandarán estos electrones
al átomo de oxígeno
así Esta es una reacción ácido base Así
que esto estará en
equilibrio continuaré poniendo nuestro
otro corchete de resonancia
así qué obtendremos aún tenemos nuestro
anillo de
benzeno intacto por
aquí y veamos ahora tenemos nuestro
grupo carbonilo
así y acabamos de agregar un protón a
este carbono justo aquí así así que
hemos terminado y puedes ver que este es
un aldeido no dibujé el hidrógeno por
aquí por lo que puedes omitirlo si
quieres pero si quieres dibujar nuestro
hidrógeno hay un hidrógeno
ahí también hay un hidrógeno en este
carbono justo aquí solo no lo dibujé
para mostrar un poco de Claridad en el
mecanismo el resultado final es que
formamos un aldeido a partir de un
alquino terminal y mostramos esta
tautomerización usando una base déjame
solo continuar y escribir una cosa más
aquí Este es un ejemplo de una
tau
meti
zación
calizada
por
una
base donde vamos de la forma enol a en
este caso un aldeido como nuestro
producto
el cual es más estable debido al doble
enlace carbono
oxígeno